[Musik]
hallo hallo herzlich willkommen sallys
welt und so samira sind heute backen wir
rathert rates eine prinzessin und orte
und zwar ist es eine schwedische
spezialität princess tat ich weiß nicht
genau wie man es ausspricht
jedenfalls ist es eine torte die von der
kochbuch autorin jenny castro so
wahrscheinlich spricht man so ähnlich
aus erfunden wurde und damals haben
damit drei prinzessinnen die torte
getestet und haben gesagt die schmeckt
ihnen am besten
und die torte besteht innen aus biskuit
böden da ist einmal laden schicht
vanillecreme ganz viel sahne und dann
wird das ganze bedeckt mit marzipan die
torte wird klassisch immergrün überzogen
und dann mit rosa rosen verziert und so
haben sie auch gemacht für die konditor
creme verwende ich 500 milliliter milch
einen teelöffel wandel extrakt 85 gramm
zucker eine prise salz 45 gramm stärke 6
1 gelbe und 45 gramm butter
die contitech geben könnt ihr auf viele
verschiedene arten machen
viele machen sie so dass er die milch
erstmal aufkochen lassen oder erhitzen
und dann die restlichen zutaten
verrühren unter zu geben
ich mache es immer ganz gerne so ich bin
gleich alles und passt einfach beim
kochen auf also zuerst mal ein bisschen
milch in den topf zucker und salz dann
noch die stärke dazu
dann kommt hier noch wenn ihr extrakt
dazu und jetzt noch die eigelbe dazu und
alles schön glatt verrühren
jetzt gehe ich hier noch langsam die
restliche wenn ich das so einstellig
sein herz auf mittel hoher hitze und
lass ihn dann während im rühren
eindecken und einmal ganz kurz aufkochen
jetzt ist die creme eingedeckt und wenn
ihr kurz wartet dann macht es ja auch
bluthochdruck und jetzt kommt hier noch
die butter mit rein
daher hat es schon aus also die löst
sich jetzt auch durch die wärme einfach
auf und so verbindet sich jetzt optimal
mit der creme dann ist nämlich perfekt
und des früheren verhindert einfach das
anbrennen am topfboden jetzt fühle ich
sehe einfach in einen teller es damit so
einfach schnellstmöglich abkühlt da
kommt jetzt frischhaltefolie direkt auf
die oberflächen damit sich keine haut
bildet und das ist jetzt im prinzip
einfach ein richtig cremiger
vanillepudding
[Musik]
wird ein biskuit verwende ich sechs eier
240 gramm zucker eine prise salz etwas
vanille extrakt und 240 gramm mehl
ich nehme jetzt so erst die eier die
sind schön zimmer war und falls ihr mal
vergessen sollte die eier vorher aus dem
kühlschrank zu nehmen
dann legte er einfach in warmes wasser
so mache ich es auch immer ganz gerne
den war dass es sich einfach besser
aufschlagen
da kommt jetzt noch salz dazu der zucker
und etwas war neil extrakt und jetzt
einfach für etwa zehn minuten schaumig
schon richtig dickes berühren
jetzt ist die eier zuckermasse richtig
schön cremig jetzt nehme ich das mehl
und zieht es kurz und hips dann
vorsichtig mit einem schneebesen unter
so sieht der bisherig perfekt aussieht
auch der fließt gaben ganz langsam nur
vom schneebesen runter und es kommt eben
durch das lange röhren was er da dürfte
wirklich nicht zu kurz rühren jetzt habe
ich hier schon zwei dinge vorbereitet
auf 20 cm durchmesser und da fühle ich
jetzt den teig 1
[Musik]
vorsichtig verteilen
da kann der biss geht schon gebacken
werden die container bis abgekühlt die
biscuit böden sind auch schon abgekühlt
jetzt geht es direkt weiter
ich werde jetzt zuerst einmal die sahne
steif schlagen dafür habe ich jetzt hier
450 milliliter sahne
da kommt ein bisschen meinl extrakt dazu
und jetzt versuche ich die sahne und
schlagt ihr dann mit seiner partei
die tortenböden habe ich jetzt bereits
durchgeschnitten und jetzt fühle ich die
sahne in einem spritzbeutel mit einer
lok hülle vorne
und jetzt kann ich mithilfe des
sprichwortes hier außen einen ring
spritzen und dein die mitte da kommt
dann die marmelade rein dann fließt sie
nämlich nicht an den rand nach außen
dann kommt ihr zur marmelade rhein habe
ziehe himbeermarmelade ihr könnt
natürlich auch erdbeeren nehmen oder
eine andere marmelade die ihr gerne habt
kurz verteilen dann kommt hier jetzt der
zweite boden drauf wieder einen ring
spritzen
stelle ich die torte ganz kurz in den
kühlschrank und hol schon mal die
konditor creme aus dem kühlschrank und
habe ich jetzt die konditor creme und
ihr seht auch hat sich keine haut drauf
gebildet und damit jetzt klümpchen die
eventuell drinnen sind verschwinden kann
ich sie jetzt hier durch ein sieb
streichen und entweder nimmt er jetzt
ein ganz normales hasi oder zum beispiel
das fleißige lieschen so geht es ein
bisschen einfacher
das weiß sie genießen das ist die kleine
schwester von der flotten lotte die
kinder vielleicht von der oma von der
mama laden zur bereitung und das
fleißige lieschen die hat einfach so
feinere löcher sag ich jetzt mal dass
ein feines haar sie und andere ist er
für marmelade für große kerne gedacht
und da geht es ein bisschen einfacher
für mich früher echte mir abgewöhnt mit
dem pudding mit dem durchstreichen vor
allem wenn ich mal einen festeren
pudding gemacht habe seine mutter
buttercreme zum beispiel
und so gehts echt super einfach das habe
ich ja hier den sand jetzt kommt hier
die konditor creme rein die hälfte aller
helfer die creme verstreichen mal ganz
vorsichtig so dass die mitte ausgefüllt
ist
sag ich sogar hilfe von einer echten
prinzessin mache nämlich gerade
schwedische prinzessin und orte
schwedische prinzessin diana hatte nicht
den pudding an rand sondern nur hier in
und zwar vanillecreme die heißt soll die
torte
[Musik]
das müssen wir kurz nach jetzt hast du
mich erwischt unsere tochter ist jetzt
schon hoch genug das heißt den letzten
boden den verwenden wir gar nicht jetzt
kommt hier einfach noch die restliche
sahne auf der torte und wird dann zu
einer kuppel gestrichen also wie ein
maulwurf torte und wenn du möchtest
kannst du aus dem letzten tortenboden
was machen
ersteigert ich habe alles
ihr könnt jetzt die torte entweder mit
einer tankkarte glattstreichen oder ihr
nehmt ich habe mir mal aus einem block
den rand weggeschnitten oder nehmt
einfach das hier so ein kleines
kunststoff stückchen und können dann
damit die torten klappt sie
und wenn die vorderen einigermaßen glatt
ist kommt sie noch mal kurz in den
kühlschrank und ich kann ihnen der
zwischenzeit schon mal die marzipan
decke vorbereiten
die torte ist jetzt gekühlt und ich
bereite jetzt die marzipan decke vor
dafür nehme ich jetzt marzipanrohmasse
und etwas butter zucker und den
puderzucker knete ich jetzt hier ein
damit ich den marzipan eben auch aus
rollen kann
[Musik]
ich werde jetzt den marzipan noch ein
einen teil lediglich mehr weg da mache
ich später noch raus und jetzt nehme ich
einfach ein bisschen verpasste in grün
und möchte einen schönen pass teltower
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt bei mir noch ein bisschen
blau dazu gegeben und jetzt habe ich
echt nen schönen richtig pastelligen ton
jetzt rolle ich die marzipan decke aus
mit etwas becker stärke geht es am
einfachsten schöne farbe gelb dann
machen wir gleich seine rosa blumen noch
dazu
darüber die torte legen und glatt
streichen
es ist auch ein bisschen schwierig weil
er die sahne creme ziemlich weich ist
also ganz glatt wie bei von dort wird
marzipan hier nicht weil es einfach eine
sehr weiche dort ist und ich kann
einfach den marzipan nicht so arg
stretchen also nicht so elastisch wie
von dort deswegen ist ganz okay wenn
unten auch zum beispiel ein paar falten
entstehen geht der chor immer dann
einfach weg manche machen sogar bewusst
ein paar falten jetzt den rand einfach
vorsichtig wegschneiden stelle ich die
torte kurz in den kühlschrank und form
schon mal eine rose
[Musik]
machen wir gerade ganz vereinfachte
rosen und zwar nimmt ihr ein bisschen
marzipan und formt ist zu einer rolle
dann ein bisschen flach drücken und
einfach mit den fingern auf rollen
und unten wegschneiden und so kann man
ganz ganz einfache rosen machen
natürlich können sie auch wie samira
großen blätter ausstechen und richtige
rosenmachen ich mache dir ganz einfach
mehr kann ich jetzt in frührente gehen
und dann mache ich alles alleine weiter
okay das auch schon mal geklärt
[Musik]
wir haben unsere torte jetzt noch mit
glitzer schnee bestreut
typischerweise wird die torte auch mit
puderzucker bestreut wir nehmen aber
schnell weil der bund ist maler bundes
und waller klettert und den gibt es in
rosa gold und silber und wer mit rosa
genommen außerdem schmilzt wenn ich an
der oberfläche
okay wir probieren jetzt und dann darf
der könig probieren ja der könig die
prinzessin habe ich hab' ich gerade
könig gehört ja hast du deine zwei
prinzessinnen haben gebacken
ja dann bin ich die königin
ich bin mal gespannt also an schneiden
lässt er sich super einfach
so sieht die torte ihnen aus als ich
hier unten hat man richtig schön den
biss geboten auch in der mitte dann
einmal die marmeladen schicht die
vanille creme und dann die sahne holt
ihr 2 probieren ist auch okay wir
probieren
ich bin ja voller toller marzipan fällt
deswegen werde ich liebe auch mal zu
pannen
ich probier einmal kurz von unten die
manet la creme ist er ist nicht zu süß
gern das ist keine mächtige top muss man
ehrlich sagen ja da kann man ruhig zwei
drei oder vier stücke essen da kein
problem
oder auch nicht ihr leben war nicht echt
lecker da hast du schöner lockerer bis
kühlt wenn es jetzt auch schön lang
entwickelt die vanille creme ist super
lecker fragen bestimmt einige warum muss
man die vanille creme mit so viel geld
machen und wenn es sorgt dafür dass die
vanillecreme auch so schön cremig wird
dadurch bekommt auch die farbe und mit
dem eiweiss könnt ihr eine tolle
resteverwertung machen ich habe schon
ganz viele eiweiß rezepte auf meinem
kanal da könnte es apps draus machen
oder pablo war also wirklich ganz viele
leckere sachen ich habe man liebt oder
hasst man gern oder so schlimm ich darf
nicht jedoch die meisten mögen es
glauben und hier mag ist ganz besonders
ich finde es auch gut dass ich meine
welt kein marzipan war und von dorf
jetzt hier keine alternative weil
einfach die creme darunter nicht von
dort geeignet ist aber man kann ja
einfach dann eine andere schicht
runtermachen eine amerikanische
buttercreme zum beispiel oder eine
swissmedic buttercreme ja damit an
deshalb keine prinzessin
wir sind gut ich auch die nur die tore
ja echt lecker und falls ihr doch er
weiß was da habt und sagt ich möchte
kein publisher machen und nichts anderes
machen können doch er weiß ein fremden
wenn sie es noch mal um den pudding
gehen müssen
falls sie das rezept gerne nachmachen
möchte schaut auf meinem kanal vorbei
dallas - blog.de
da steht alles noch mal ganz genau ich
freue mich auf eure version der torte
ich habe sie gerade angespuckt leiter es
tut mir leid gesehen und verlinkt mich
auf jeden fall auf euren bildern und
dann schaue ich da gerne mal rein also
bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]